well uh let's jump into the first story
it's really hard for me to care about
this to be completely honest but
apparently like everybody's tweeting
about it I know world war three is
trending Haley Biden revealed his new
Biden family member who got China cash
and I'm just like I don't care I don't
know man there's nothing that the Biden
family could be revealed to be doing at
this point which is going to make me go
oh egat I can't believe that happened
you know like I already think Joe
Biden's a pedophile you know that's my
personal opinion I mean but I'm pretty
sure his son Hunter calls him that pedo
Peter whatever so like the fact that
Biden's was his daughter Biden's Hunter
Biden's sister-in-law turned former
lover was was subpoenaed uh had revealed
in subpoenaed bank records that she had
received Chinese cash in 2017. I'm just
like
they took more money from a from a place
they weren't supposed to take money from
with no consequences I mean is there
ever going to be any shocking there's no
reason to care about it because nothing
will happen I mean of course you should
be outraged but do we expect anyone to
be prosecuted for this no really Biden
family fatigue right on all of it like
even so it's it's uh with the the Polish
stuff I don't want to get into too much
of the Ukraine war because we're talking
about bidens but just as an aside
we were talking about the Downing of the
U.S drone and then I can't remember who
said it but they were like this will be
used as a pretext to send Jets to
Ukraine and it's like oh sure and like a
day later it literally happens we were
talking with Steve Bannon last week and
he's like guys come Monday they're going
to tell you to bail out this Bank say no
literally the next morning they're like
we're bailing out the bank and so it's
just like did the system break like is
it just done we've all seen this film
before yeah like oh it's gonna happen
it's it's and not just that but like the
system has shattered to the point where
people are just doing whatever they feel
like doing regardless of the
consequences yeah the power it's
starting to become more apparent that
power is what controls Society really I
mean love and caring and all that crap
it's important to build stable societies
but Power will do what power wants power
takes well maybe okay so I have an
optimistic view on this underwhelming
awful story maybe that means no war with
China everything's fine Biden family is
corrupt they're taking money from China
good relationship there we're all saved
yay no I think it means war with China
because uh what's going to happen is the
bidens are corrup they're destroying the
economy their policy his policies are
trash he's he's not paying attention he
doesn't care he's completely incapable
even if he did care and the economy is
in free fall banks are collapsing Credit
Suisse is next and that collapse is
going to lead to a dramatic
transformation in this country one way
or the other and and the end result is
going to be the weakening of the country
and China taking an opportunity to
strike China's already told the United
States you are not negotiating from us
from a position of power so anything
that happens at this point even Donald
Trump getting reelected that'll be an
upswing in my opinion but China's going
to be like uh oh Donald Trump's winning
in the polls we better strike now before
he wins
Taiwan okay right and then then
southeast Asia destabilizes or falls
under Chinese Communist influence we
lose that influence
I don't know how much I care about that
I I because I'm I'm at the point where
I'm kind of resigned to
Millennials and gen Z in this country
need to learn how to break rocks and
chop wood or something because they are
so entitled and lazy this country is
going to fall apart unless we actually
teach them how to I don't know look
they're they're they're they're doughy
doughy soy boys yeah our country is not
going to survive if it's being led by
doughy soy boys and it is I've been
watching a lot of carpentry videos it's
pretty sweet joint uh joinery joining
wood I mean you don't need Nails you
just cut the right angles and then set
it on itself and you create these Super
structurally Sound yeah sorry obviously
have you seen the Japanese ones they're
like weird and they like yeah stick
together and like lock and play cool
stuff there are all kinds of skills that
we used to have that we are forgetting
like I grew up in New England so there
are lots of stone walls well there used
to be people who could assemble stone
walls with no cement because they knew
how to identify the way the Rocks would
bounce and they stood for hundreds and
hundreds of years and I I knew a man who
this was his family trait like he
learned it from his grandfather and his
son was unfortunately addicted to
opioids was not in a position to learn
it and he died before he could pass it
on to his grandchild that's a whole
generation of people who built stone
walls and that skill is completely gone
like there are all kinds of Handy skills
that we just gave up because we believe
that we are completely internet laptop
bound generation I kind of think like
the doughy soy boys are going to result
in a very shattered tattered and
destroyed government which will create a
hard time which will result in strong
times like I don't think anyone needs to
make someone chop wood they're gonna
have to chop wood themselves because
otherwise they'll freeze to death it's
just the economy is failing you know
whether intentionally otherwise control
demolition call it what you want and
these doughy soy boys are going to go
out one day and be like where's the
heater and it's going to be like there
ain't one you best learn how to make a
wood stove and chop some wood and if
they can't then they'll simply freeze to
death doe is a generous description I
think I think do we I think they're not
all they're wet noodles wet noodles is
probably not appropriate yeah well some
of them are pretty doughy though too
much glutens too much your gluten that's
where you get the dough I don't know man
I'm seeing all these videos of people
being like I was misgendered and it's
just like that's so sad wow China's
gonna walk into the United States and
they're gonna they already have but in
the way they're buying Farmland that's
the way they're walking say with Taiwan
what they'll do is they'll get them to
vote it to be China because they'll have
spies there that overthrow the
government without anyone knowing there
won't be guns and shot no one wants to
fire guns really I'm with you I don't
think that China and the us are going to
war I think it's actually indicative
that it won't that they've been trying
to avoid World War III which is why
they're building a new world order and
they're happy to sell out now whether or
not peaceful slavery is better than a
war I don't know or I mean if the United
States dollar is no longer the the unit
of measurement that the United that the
whole world uses to sort of you know
measure itself against if the dollar
just goes away
and Chinese currency Rises to the top
that could be another thing maybe the
United States isn't going to go to war
with any other major world power maybe
we're just going to become irrelevant
yeah but as long as we have strong
borders you know I'm cool with it but if
we don't and then it becomes a unipolar
Chinese World Chinese Communist world uh
that would really really suck but as
long as we're not at War and there's not
troops on our ground in the United
States I don't really care like I don't
I don't believe in the United States
Global hegemony I'm not for that and if
that goes away if if our military bases
across the globe go away I'm okay with
that what happens 10 years after that
maybe nothing I mean how about others
China's already expanding into Africa
South America the Belton Road initiative
so if we go away China fills that vacuum
in their real real nasty people the
Chinese Communists belt one road hasn't
been very financially successful though
but yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure that
matters so much I mean a lot of what the
US does is predicated upon just military
might and the financial stuff makes no
sense they they're they're going to
infuse two trillion dollars in loans to
try and keep liquidity in a collapsing
system they'll just do whatever well it
doesn't last forever you've got China
right now uh raping and torturing uyghur
Muslims so it's kind of like man I don't
know if I want to live in a world where
they're the dominant military superpower
I'm not saying that's happening anytime
soon but not that I like what the US
does overseas I think it's I think it's
BS for the most part but uh I'm also
willing to recognize that uh
the world's going to fall under the
control of of one group
at some point okay you know there's that
famous quote I think it was from uh was
it Nathaniel Rothschild or something and
he said globalism it's not a question of
of like how it will happen it's a
question of or if it's not a question of
if it will happen it's a question of
when and there's nothing anyone can do
to stop it or something like that you
want to look up the quote Yeah but it
hasn't happened yet but what people
misunderstood I think with that quote is
they they ascribe it to him as though
he's saying he is going to make it
happen and there is nothing anyone can
do to stop him when I think what he was
really saying was the natural trend of
power structures is to coalesce and the
world will fall under one governing
Authority it already has for the most
part the Swift payment system whether or
not that holds out for a total you know
uh executive Authority whether whether
we advance that point with the United
States in the west I'm not sure it could
be that China does it you know it could
be a Chinese Communist Global Authority
right now it's like St I think China's
basically winning and that's why we
referred a lot of the Davos group stuff
and the world economic Forum stuff as
like CCP chinese-style communism
absolutely so it's like the US is
already losing this one
I can't find the who this quote I know
what you're talking about though was it
a Rothschild quote for sure pretty sure
um what do you see Angela like as a
better because I don't like the military
industrial complex at all I mean I but I
I'm starting to gain respect for what it
has done which is prevent World War III
prevent communist slavery like I'm
allowed to say I'm allowed to criticize
Joe Biden with that I mean I'm not
convinced that we have staved off China
taking over the United States I'm not
convinced that China actually has that
in their sights I don't I'm not
convinced that that's in their aim do I
like Chinese communism no I think
communism is really horrendous but I
don't actually believe that they're that
they're dead set on trying to take us
over and that our giant military power
is the only thing that's staving them
off what do you think China's objective
is like why are they making investments
in other countries I think that they
want to become a financial superpower I
think that that's really what they want
and I think that that's why would they
want that if not to like be in control
well there's different types of control
right like if you don't if you don't
feel comfortable with bloody World War
III Warfare why not just try to get as
much Financial control as possible and
become the fine Financial superpower I
don't think that it's the same as going
out and committing acts of mass murder
I'm very wary of a social credit system
and anything like that anything ESG
social credit anything that smacks of
CCP but I'm not so much worried about
troops on the ground over here or on
Mexico you know I feel like China invade
should become a new drinking game like
every time someone brings up China
invades to take a drink yeah it's a
wonderful Boogeyman you can always say
those guys that don't speak my language
and they can't disprove it because they
don't speak English no one will listen
to them anyway right you guys are saying
that China will not invade Taiwan I was
saying they would not invade the United
States oh well I mean that's very
different yes very oh they'll take
Taiwan in two seconds I'm not I'm not
I'm not so sure about Taiwan Taiwan is
very very touch and go I think I think
it would be opportunistic I think that's
what's going to happen so there are some
so it depends on your definition I
suppose there are some islands that are
part of Taiwan that are extremely close
to Mainland China which are already at
risk but they're like rocks so it's not
no one really cares but China's already
sent uh fighter jets into Taiwanese air
defense zones they've already done this
they've already blockaded the island
multiple times they're also building
Islands yeah they're they're building a
lot of military bases on Art of on our
artificial Islands so you know I don't
know we'll we'll see what happens I
guess my question is like what would be
better than the military-industrial
complex I feel like the liberal economic
order is the military-industrial complex
that order of Economics that
american-led
um and then it's evolving into this new
world order of some sort we're creating
a global economy a global system what
would be better that what's the
evolution that you see they would be
better than the military bases all over
Earth isolationism
I mean you know in a perfect world I'm
very very pro-free trade I think that
when when Goods don't cross borders
troops will free trade would be
definitely like what I think we should
have
um and and I think that you know
cryptocurrency and especially Bitcoin is
something that makes that possible so
that you can sort of bypass all of this
world economic Forum BS but uh if we
can't achieve that then I would just
want isolationism what isolationism I
think is is kind of accepted that that's
the cause the reason World War II kicked
off the way it kicked off because the
United States didn't want to get
involved until it was too late I think
that it would have gone just fine if the
United States had not gotten involved I
don't think the U.S intervention was
necessary in World War II really really
I mean it was the Russians and the
Germans versus France and Britain I
think they were already winning
the Reddit there was just the French
were taken over in two weeks and then
the British no not French no not the
French the British I think the British
were already winning the war when we got
in I think they were going to win it was
going to be
ugly
ugly Victory you know pretty brutal but
they were already bringing it home I
guess the U.S had funded them throughout
the war supplied weapons weapons so that
we I have a collection of old life
magazines that I bought an antique store
it's really cool to read about like it
was like three months before D-Day there
were reports that the U.S was staging
weapons in the UK for defensive purposes
and only now do we look back on history
and go oh they were planning on invading
program so so there are photos of all of
this crazy U.S military ordinance and
materials in the UK like we had been
like whether if it was the British
soldiers that were weddings because we
were basically giving them weapons yeah
and keep in mind that Nazi Germany was
collapsing on the inside too like they
had totally burned through all of their
artillery their economy was just
absolutely just going up in smoke it was
it was a disaster over there so they
pushed really hard with German
Blitzkrieg strategy through everything
that they had at the at the war and then
it just ran out
so that was that was you know it's it's
not just like the United States came in
and just yay you know War over there was
so many things going on in that war like
I in an isolation an isolationist state
if we were would that just be me
National isolationism like where would a
couple questions where would the where
would it stop like how local would the
isolation become
uh I think it would be the federal
government just pulling out of as many
things internationally as possible and
then what if foreign countries start
polluting the air or like destroying the
ecosystem and then we're like hey guys
stop and they're like nah well I mean
they already are but we have bases kind
of like with nukes pointed at them and
you're like you're gonna stay in the
Paris Accord you're gonna do these
things
yeah not that it's a winning strategy
but there's like a deterrent to
completely annihilating your environment
for profit I don't know if that's a
really like a big concern that everyone
has I think right now developing
countries are polluting so that they can
catch up with the rest of the first
world and and maybe that's okay China is
definitely heavy on pollution I don't
know that they care of that that much
what about space space colonization if
we're isolationists and not involved in
China's colonization of mars or or if we
weren't doing it together where take it
to the moon like just you don't think
that would result in war if yeah that'll
definitely result in war explain it
again if we're not doing it together
let's not even go that far and say
Antarctica should the U.S have territory
Antarctica
who cares
the research scientists in Antarctica
but why do we care about what they care
about it's Antarctica it's a chunk of
ice for now so I mean but by that logic
you're saying that none of what the
United States does matters outside of
the United States not very much so like
scientific research done outside of this
country is irrelevant
I don't think it's irrelevant but I
don't think it's worth going to war over
so then like what what's what's your
view of a functioning country then I
mean Antarctica I think is an
interesting question for Libertarians in
this regard because there there's
limited claims it's like everybody has a
sliver of it yeah and there's extremely
important research being done there
particularly drilling into the ice and
then tracking the state of the planet
over the past ten thousand years or
whatever and the you know fossil records
and things like that is going to grant
us a tremendous amount of information
which can probably be applied to
evolutionary biology which could
potentially be applied to genetics or
who knows what so we should just say no
we should give we should ignore all
potential new territories to foreign
countries
I would not go to war over Antarctica
that's how I would draw the line what if
there's like a new material discovered
on the moon that will allow China to
make a devastating new weapon
and we are there and we have a base
and
like should we just abandon the base and
be like we don't want to we don't want
to get into a conflict with China
because they're interested in the space
well that's pretty far out there I mean
that's why I say Antarctica on the moon
what event what if China starts making
advancements in Antarctica pressing them
pressing into the U.S borders should we
Retreat because we don't go to war
I think it really depends it's a
cost-benefit analysis and sometimes you
do have to seed ground that's that's
what I'm kind of arguing and advocating
for in the Ukraine Russia conflict
I mean the difference with Ukraine is
that it's it's useless to us it's a NATO
NATO wants this territory to expand they
want to expand their influence Russia
doesn't want to give up control of of a
border of a land bridge to one of its
only warm water I think it's only warm
water port in the Black Sea so they're
saying no NATO has no real interest in
it other than there's pipelines running
through it and they want to get energy
from you know the cutter turkey pipeline
up into Europe to lower the cost of gas
but that's an economic thing based on
gas and the United States and NATO are
unwilling to give that up to Russia
despite the fact that Russia had in the
first place so in this instance it's the
U.S pushing on Russia to take from them
it's an inversion to the analogy of
Antarctica so it's interesting uh what
about diplomacy because that's something
that's been really missing in the
Ukraine Russia conflict and I think that
diplomacy is something that the United
States should always employ no matter
what the conflict is the U.S and the
West tried diplomacy with Syria and
Syria said no
well can you expand on that a little bit
because there was a lot going on the
west Western forces wanted a pipeline
running through Syria turkey into Europe
to offset the gas prom gas Monopoly
Syria said no this would upset our Ally
Russia well I think that we have not
been treating Russia with a with a lot
of respect and we have to respect that
Syria has a relationship with them
sometimes I think Russia should
surrender because going to war with the
United States is not worth it to defend
territory it's not part of Russia in
which Con in which respect all Syria and
Ukraine I would love if they did yeah
they should have let the U.S just take
all that land
well why not
I mean it's none of our business right
ultimately I would think we should not
be involved in any of those conflicts
well it's not Russia so why is it
Russia's business
it's not our business to to police the
world so if we're in Antarctica minding
our own business and China starts
expanding we should Retreat because it's
none of our business I think the first
thing we should do is try to engage in
diplomacy and see what's going on there
and then when that fails we should
Retreat because none of our business
potentially so when it came to building
a pipeline through Syria Russia should
have said Syria let the United States do
whatever they want because going to war
is not worth it give them the pipeline
when it came to Ukraine Russia should
have said no no diplomacy has failed but
war is worse so we should we should
Retreat and give our border states to to
Nato in the west because it's not worth
going to war over I think our position
should always be diplomacy I don't think
that we can always sure in a perfect
world everyone should be diplomatic but
we can only be accountable for our own
actions right I guess I guess my issue
is
Russia has there's I think what like
Latvia and Estonia are on the border and
NATO absorbs them and now they've got
NATO on their border which was like they
were treated saying that we wouldn't do
this and it ends up happening anyway
Ukraine is on their border and they're
they are selling guests legitimately
through gas problem and other natural
gas companies through a pipeline into
Europe the United States doesn't like
that Russia makes money off this to this
degree and they don't like how much they
charge for it so the United States goes
to Syria and says we want to run a
pipeline through your country Syria says
no diplomacy fails the U.S decides to
destabilize Syria in a matter of
speaking they say Assad is gassing his
own people and he's a bad guy and sure
probably I don't know but but either way
it's so darn convenient for the U.S that
Syria destabilizes it's so darn
convenient for the U.S that Ukraine
destabilizes and then Russia takes a
land bridge in the Eastern portion into
Crimea where it enacts annexes Crimea
because it has a warm water Port there
the argument is Russia should let us do
whatever we want because we are not in
Russia we are in other countries no one
should stand in our way when the United
States does whatever it wants because
Russia is not Ukraine because Syria is
not Russia Russia should not have gotten
involved at all and that also means if
Russia sends military forces into Mexico
and weapons and starts building military
bases and sending weapons there we
should be totally okay with it and let
them do whatever they want because
Mexico is not the United States so it
sounds to me from all of this that the
United States needs to scale back its
military dramatically and maybe we don't
deserve to have a little bit of land in
Antarctica since we're taking it from
everywhere else across well then Russia
doesn't deserve to have it either but
why are they taking it who's gonna who's
gonna stop them from doing it Welcome to
The Human Condition I mean right and so
the the issue at hand is there is no
simple answer where the United States is
the bad guy every country is doing the
exact same thing
maybe this is like an enpoint coming
back to Power in the United States has
the most military power and there is a
little bit of an imbalance right now
they may have I'm not so sure that's the
case anymore the United States economy
is is is
in the gutter I mean it's not just the
United States it's NATO and it is a
massive military power
but there's also strengths and
weaknesses so technologically in terms
of air superiority I think the U.S is
you know typically heralded as the most
powerful in terms of aircraft carriers a
lot of things but China is the largest
standing ground army yes I think North
Korea has a crap ton of ground troops as
well and the important thing that people
need to realize is a fighter jet can't
occupy a street corner so while we may
have the capability to wipe out a whole
country with a barrage of mervs nuclear
warheads or you know bombard a city with
a fighter jet when it comes to actually
controlling territory we are not the
most powerful in terms of being able to
do that we would need a combined Force
to actually try and do it and if you
look at Afghanistan and Iraq not so easy
for us to pull off or especially Vietnam
so anyway long story short we do have a
lot of power and the United States does
do a lot of things we don't like the
issue is there's no simple answer in if
the if if the argument is we shouldn't
be doing it because none of our business
the same argument applies to any other
country China Russia or otherwise and no
one stopping them from doing it it's
basically I look at it like water
flowing downhill sure you might be like
we should try and stop that water
flowing downhills like dude it's water
flowing downhill you know what I mean we
want to prevent War for sure I don't
know how how you go about doing that
when all of these forces have to collide
with each other
I certainly think what the US is doing
in many ways is complete BS and we
should not be in Ukraine because we are
basically sending our interests into a
border country with Russia and of course
Russia's pissed and then we and now
they're who was it uh on TV said uh I
think it was Kamala Harris she was on
Colbert and she was like Vladimir Putin
is committing crimes against humanity
and everyone starts clapping and
cheering and I'm like this these goons
clapping I don't even know what they're
talking about Vladimir Putin's certainly
not a good dude to the imagination but
it's like the US is either right it's a
bunch of crackpot War mongers fighting
for power and control and it's all
basically the same crap as far as I'm
concerned yeah I mean we need to get out
of entangling alliances and it is
incredibly entangled right now and try
to engage in diplomacy
um and it's unfortunate that the people
in positions of Power are not inclined
to do so because they they generate
Financial wealth based on all these
tragedies happening across the globe I
think the big problem is
Donald Trump's a strong guy he's a
strong man quite literally that's what
they call him and he was working towards
peace with say North Korea and South
Korea he signed the Abraham Accords
there was a lot that he was doing to try
and simmer things down but from a
position of strength Joe Biden is
corrupt and I don't think actually cares
about anything other than
the hard numbers yeah which is why we're
reading a story about his families
getting money from China I didn't care
about China he just wants money for
himself and his family that is going to
lead to war that is going to lead to the
conflict and the downfall because that
is what ends up providing massive
funding to the military-industrial
complex a corrupt family saying
something like look I don't care if we
blow up a hundred thousand civilians how
much do I get in Kickbacks and then all
of a sudden 10 for the big guy so his
kids get paid then he gets a cut of the
salary and then the world Falls to crap
that seems to be what the Biden family's
been all about for the past decade or
you know several decades honestly and
Donald Trump was like let's have peace
defend our borders bring manufacturing
back and I'm like all of those are good
things
but when you have a system of neoliberal
crony capitalism
then you're going to end up with a
corporate press that wants to make money
they will do whatever they have to do to
make money and that means they'll Pony
up for any intelligence agency that
wants to maintain maintain power they'll
say whatever the advertisers want them
to say they'll push whatever narrative
is generating money for them they won't
push back against politicians see the
thing is these networks they want Pac
money they when it comes election season
oh boy you're going to get paid so if
you're NBC for instance and you keep
ragging telling the truth about the
Biden family well all of a sudden the
Biden packs aren't buying ads anymore I
mean that's tens of billions of dollars
you might lose over the course of a few
election Cycles your best bet is to shut
your mouth say nothing Donald Trump
didn't spend nearly as much money as
Hillary Clinton did and that's part of
the reason why we see so many TV
channels ragging on Trump he doesn't buy
from them he doesn't he doesn't give
them money so they don't care Hillary
Clinton's people were spending tons of
money on the media and they're like we
don't want to lose these customers
they're paying the bills so this is a
big problem anyway long story short
that's why Independent Media is so
important you know my problem with
isolationism I keep thinking about World
War II like the way that the French saw
Hitler expanding his growing his
military rapidly and then with the eyes
and the East and the sudate and land and
stuff but the French were just like
we're not going to stop them we're we're
Live and Let Live we'll use diplomacy
Hitler was like yeah we're great friends
yeah we're just going to build some more
tanks we're great friends violating
treaties building tanks and the French
are like we're just gonna have a strong
defense a defensive border wall and the
Germans just plowed through it the the
Arden Forest they were like they built
the majino line this huge defensive
trench line series of trenches and
they're like no nothing can get through
this but there's a thick dense forested
area called the Arden forest and the
Germans took these new technological
things these tanks these Panzer tanks
never seen before just plowed through
the forest into France into Paris like
in a week so if you just sit there and
wait and just hope that he's gonna go
say what he's going gonna do like
they're gonna find a technology that can
breach your defenses that's my fear of
isolationism well it's definitely not
preferable to me over free trade and
diplomacy and and you know positive
international relations but I prefer it
over globalism for sure
globalism would yeah I think I think
globalism is inevitable and it's because
power coalesces no matter what I'm not
saying that Global communism is
inevitable but trade lines will
inevitably result in international
agreements which will eventually result
in international law enforcement which
which will ultimately result in
international courts which will
ultimately result in international
legislative bodies and then you have
globalism we basically have it now I
just want to I want the ability to be
able to opt out of globalism I don't
want Global rule to be something that
everyone is subject to
does that make sense it's governance
yeah Global governance but I think no
matter what happens it it will be there
well I mean you already exists I mean
look you you can go and live in the
woods and for the most part you're fine
but if you want to be in this system the
system is increasingly coalescing around
itself like it's it's it's forming a
hard shell yeah yeah if you're in it
you're in it well I mean it used to be
that if you committed a serious crime
let's go back to the 1800s if you like
were a train like a bandito and you
robbed a train and killed some guy you
could ride off a thousand miles west
change your name and nobody would have
any idea that'd be the end of it you'd
you'd go from being John Smith to Jack
Williams and people would be like oh how
do you back I'm just you know coming up
and here's the work that I did and I'm
looking for a job and that's it you
can't do that today if you're in the
United States and you commit a crime you
go to a foreign country they're going to
find you and they're going to depending
on that if they have an extradition
treaty it is all increasingly becoming
one small world where you're gonna look
you know you want you want you want to
know the evidence of globalism already
happening
every single City I've gone to the
tourist districts have the exact same
stores sure they've got Dolce they've
got uh whatever they got Starbucks
McDonald's Hard Rock Cafe bubble gum
shrimp one of the most brutal things
ever was when I went to the Bahamas I
was I think is that word as NASA yeah
and uh I was like oh this is gonna be
really cool it's like it's like a
different country basically and you get
off the boat and I walk in and I'm like
am I in Times Square like it's the same
thing it's identical thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time